we've waited seven years already so
what's another two months right yes
we're so to say the last guardian has
been delayed again was previously given
up Tober 25th release date but will now
launch when December 6 2016 I'm tomorrow
and I'm sorry to be the bearer of bad
news on this gamespot news update an
update on the PlayStation Blog Sony
Computer Entertainment worldwide studios
president Shuhei Yoshida explained that
the extra time was needed to fix bugs he
said the last guardian development team
is fast approaching major milestones in
production and has made the tough
decision to delay the release of the
Last Guardian a few weeks a delay is a
difficult decision particularly with
this game but we have encountered more
bugs and anticipated while in the final
stages of development to ensure the Last
Guardian delivers on the experience that
the game's creators have envisioned we
need to take the extra time to work on
those issues he added for me to aveda
and japan studios have a wonderful
vision for the last Guardians touching
emotional journey of friendship and
trust and we want to deliver the most
polish experience possible for our fans
who have supported us for so long are
you looking forward to the last guardian
disappointed at the delays let us know
in the comments or come and find me on
Twitter I'm add two more H and for the
latest on the Last Guardian make sure to
keep a gamespot
you